e
e e
so it's a little past one it's division
two and we'll open the meeting with the
Department of education and please
introduce yourself my name is Mark Mello
with the Department of Education Bureau
of school Finance um uh today the focus
is adequacy um you have a couple of
documents in front of you uh you have
the orientation package that we provided
on January 13th if you already have this
I plan on just using this as a reference
if you want to discuss this today
because we had didn't cover all you know
33 pages in here um so if we want to
refer back to it we can um if you
already have a
you can just pass it off to Mickey and
and you know it'll just be around for
someone to pick up um the other document
here you already have this from the
January 13th training however I've
highlighted a few communities um and
we're just going to walk through this
spreadsheet because we did not do that
back in
January the new documents are we have
excess swep documents um so we're going
to dig in those dig into that a little
bit you have a handout a town by town of
the excess swept communities
and then you have a a sort of hyp
hypothetical walkthrough of what's going
to happen if excess swept becomes um the
law of the land via the Rand the Rand
issue that's currently in the Supreme
Court um and we'll talk about how that
would impact communities using these
tools um just to step back a little bit
before we talk about adequacy I think um
just spending some time in the education
funding committee uh uh uh room seeing
some themes as far as what issues might
make their way to D2 um seeing a lot of
swept bills so um going through swept
today I think is going to be helpful um
if you do have some swept bills that may
get into this committee um other issues
uh we're seeing a lot of nutrition
program bills uh we're seeing EFA bills
we're seeing special education bills in
that committee um so you're going to
have a chance to learn um some of the
new members or people not uh used to
digging into the details with education
funding um those are just some of the
themes we're seeing in that committee so
so um getting a baseline understanding
uh today and this week would be would be
helpful
um so we're just going to walk through
the formula for three towns we have
Albany Allenstown and
Alton
um so Albany and Allenstown are pretty
similar they're not excess swept
communities um but we're just going to
walk through their data and then Alton
is an excess swept community and we're
going to be talking about that um so the
adequacy formula as most of you know um
and if you've received this training um
the formula it does change every year
but a lot of it stays the same um so we
have Albany Allenstown and Alton
highlighted there the First Column is
their membership um as we've discussed
before as most of you know uh membership
is is the town responsible for educating
that student so if Albany has students
that are receiving a home education and
are not to the responsibility of the
district they're not part of their
membership if they have students going
to a non-public uh uh non-public school
school that the district's not paying
for sometimes a district can pay to send
your kid to a student to a non-public
school um um whatever it may be if the
student is not part of the district
they're not part of the membership so
it's who are the students that Alban is
responsible for educating um and Albany
doesn't run any schools they actually
tuition students out however they are
responsible for educating those students
who live in that district and that's
where we're measuring there is um
average um average daily membership in
residents so they reside in Albany they
reside in Allenstown they reside in
Alton
um alen's another example they send
their students to Penbrook so their admr
these 503 students are they what they're
responsible but they're sending students
to
Pembrook um um so that's the first
measurement and that's just how we
measure students uh for the adequacy
formula um you might explain how you get
an e of 81 8/10 of a student yes yes so
that's the average daily membership part
um so we are looking at a student we're
looking at a student throughout the full
school year inadequacy one year is one
year behind so we would look at school
year 24 25 to uh for uh and we use that
data for fiscal year 26 um but um it's
average daily membership and daily
membership so we're looking at a
student's full school year so full for
school year
2425 um we estimate that there's going
to be 57.8 students and um that's just a
a matter of applying percentages and
coming up with an estimate but you can
um have 57.8 students because if a
student was there for 4 fths of the year
they would be 08 of a student um and so
what we're doing is we have a data
collection from the school districts
they tell us um at the end of the year
they told us who was there at the first
day of school and who was there at the
last day of school and if you're there
at the first day of school and the last
day of school you're one student if you
were there for the first day it's 180
days you were there for 90 days um and
you weren't there for the next 90 days
you're 05 student um so that's how we're
doing that measurement um whenever
you're trying to write education law
It's always important to remember how
you going to Define student um one of
the first things you have to decide is
are you going to be is it going to be a
snapshot count you going to say October
1st let's look at where these students
are which is data we do collect or you
get to look at the full school year um
also when you're defining student you
want to think about what grade levels
ages all these other metrics as well um
but average daily membership or
enrollment um sometimes we use them
interchangeably but in the law you do
need to be specific in how you use those
terms um so we're telling up all those
students um getting the average daily
members and residence and then we're um
uh multiplying it by something called
base adequacy Aid um so that is a metric
uh so one student is worth worth
$426
64 um you know for Albany we're going to
take 57.8 students and we're going to
multiply by the
4,265 and we're going to get
$246,500
um so that is base adequacy Aid um and
now if you're curious about the history
of Base adequacy a uh we had
representative Bean was discussing about
uh a little bit about the history uh
before before we started the committee
meeting um a lot of this history some of
it's legislative some of it happened in
this room uh a lot of it happened in
this room uh uh but to understand some
of the rationale for this you'd have to
read the 2008 committee report it was a
legislative report to study how they
would address adequacy and so there's a
2008 report where they basically looked
at teacher salaries they looked at what
they think would comprise an adequate
education and then they started
assigning cost to it and so they went
through that exercise of a thinking what
what do we think what what kind of
teachers do we want to have in a school
um what kind of PR principles guidance
counselors Etc and they come up with
this
methodology um uh uh and then they
divided it by the number of students
they' expect those resources to educate
and so they came up with a number this
was in 2008 they came up with a number
of I think it was like
$3,455 so that was a number they came
back up with back then based on that
report of course if you uh um we've
discussed this but there's that number
this number this this $4,260 number and
as well as that 2 uh um 8 number of
3,455 or whatever it was exactly that is
being litigated so it was litigated in
conal in
2019 um it's still being litigated in
conal in essentially what the school
districts who have sued the state have
said that number doesn't provide
inadequate
education and there's been uh uh
multiple Court hearings and and back and
forth to the Supreme Court back to the
Superior Court um but right now it's
being litigated um and so the latest
order from a superior court not the
Supreme Court is that that number should
be $
7,356 and that was a a trial that took
place uh in the spring of uh uh the
spring of 2023 the order came out I
believe last fall um now it's in the
Supreme Court's hands so the Supreme
Court is now going decide is that number
that 700 uh 7,356 number is that number
uh uh whatever we don't know what
they're going to do um but they're going
to look at that number um so as far as
how's this came up with there was that
2008 report that came up with a study
that came up with a number and then
state law plugged that number right into
State Statute so that's how we got here
um and then there's a bunch of
litigation to follow um that's still
ongoing so that's that's sort of where
we're at with that number and and where
it exists um but um yeah you can
certainly study up on that
history um the next metric besides base
adequacy Aid um and this goes back to
that 2008 report um when they were
studying adequacy and what it should be
um there's a couple factors that the
committee thought were important to uh
uh uh provide additional funding and in
that 2008 report um they referenced
poverty is something that requires extra
funding so they used free and reduced
price meals as the metric of poverty and
they decided to provide differential Aid
and extra money um for educating those
students they also looked at special
education English language learner um
there was also a third grade reading
component that's now gone uh so we don't
need to go down that rabbit hole but uh
um this is all back to that legislative
history of 2008
um so what lives today now is we provide
additional aid for f&r students um uh
which was also in that report but also
still in state law and in this formula
um so for those Albany students we are
going to look at those 57.8 students and
then we are going to um look at which
students are uh free and reduced price
meal eligible and for each student that
we can identify is free and reduced
price meal eligible we're going to
multiply that by
$2,392 192 so that one Albany student
you're getting base a Aid you're also on
top of that getting free and reduced
price meals uh differential Aid so um
you know to take that 4200 plus the
2,300 that would be for one student that
one student that's fnr eligible um that
would be the aid for that at a student
level that's how you would measure that
Aid um so when we do that for Albany 77k
for alltown 517k and for Alton
246k um the things with fre free and
reduced price meals um this committee's
received uh uh uh has talked about this
a lot is how do you identify those
students so there's two ways to identify
them there's the application so a family
fills out the application and if they're
within
185% of the federal poverty guideline um
they are marked eligible and they submit
that sta to data to the department and
then we know that that student filled
out an application was determined
eligible um so there's filling out the
application the other way is direct
certification
so if you are um an individual who
signed up for SNAP uh these are DHHS
entitlement programs snap or tanif a
program that does have a means test to
it um and you're determined eligible for
that program uh we have data sharing
that's allowed um this is data sharing
is regulated by uh the federal
government um uh but it's allowed that
we can pass snap data and tanif data
from DHHS to the Department of Education
and we can identify those students as
directly certified through that program
so if they did not fill out the
application we are still able to
identify those students as fnr and
that's called direct
certification um it can get a little
complicated well a little there's a
little wrinkle there as far as um if
you're
185% of the federal poverty guideline
you fill out the form but with SNAP
there's some a fiscal committee
established a policy two years ago that
you can be eligible for SNAP if you're
200% of the federal poverty guideline so
if you're 200% % of the pedal Federal
property guideline under snap um you can
directly certify um and still be
eligible as fnr under this program so
that's a um generally it's 185 unless
you're um uh 200% and on snap um then
you would be termined uh fnr
eligible and the key thing to remember
about that is that money is not meant to
go to nutrition that money is
unrestricted money for your school so
that uh you know 97.8 million Statewide
it's not restri restricted to to meals
it's not restricted to those students
it's unrestricted money to go to uh uh
to go to your school district it's
essentially targeting your school
district as having extra needs so you
get extra money but um uh it doesn't uh
it doesn't go directly to uh a
particular school with a high f&r count
it's unrestricted for the
district um moving on to special
education Aid is differential Aid um
same process if the student is uh uh in
our uh sped bu uh special education
Bureau database as H having an IEP um we
are going to match that student with uh
um um with their base adequacy amount
and we're going to provide them
additional Aid of
$2,184 184 in special education Aid uh
so uh that multiplied by uh that amount
uh gets us uh for Albany gets us
36,42 for Allenstown uh 106 uh students
times that amount is
230k um and that's how uh special
education differential Aid works again
it's not restricted to uh those
students um English language learner um
same process if the student is an
English language learner which is a uh
part of the title 3 Program of uh it's a
federally regulated program um if the
student is an English language learner
we multiply those admrs um uh time those
amounts times those amounts right there
and we get um English language learner
Aid um and so we're telling this all up
to get the cost of inadequate education
cost of inadequate education it's that
base amount that fnr differential Aid
that special education differential Aid
English language learner differential
Aid I I'll there's some some hidden
columns here I'll say one more thing um
the recent law passed that now we always
pay home
education uh differential Aid
essentially which means if a student
it's not a lot of money it's about
$100,000 Statewide but if a student is
home educated so they have they're not
enrolled in the district they're not
going to get a degree from their
District because they're home educated
but they would like to take a course in
their District they are entitled to do
that um and we will now collect class
information on that student and will'll
basically convert that class information
that course information into an ADM and
then compensate the school district so
um uh Statewide that's not a lot of
students it's a a few dozen students
that do that and so that's also part of
the formula it's just a tiny part of the
formula but we're telling up all those
students and we're getting the cost of
an adequate education and uh the way
that works is essentially we've
determined you need this amount under
state law to provide an adequate
education but before we pay that we're
going to look at the swept and so what
the swept is essentially is the state
needs to raise $363
million um Statewide
and so we look at the the tax base the
entire state tax base without with
excluding utilities and it's about $300
billion and we go what is it what is it
what are we going to need to tax every
single uh Community 363 million over the
entire swept tax base and it turns out
to be a rate of about a11 12 per th000
and so when we apply that tax rate of A1
12 per th000 to all of these communities
it raises an amount and essentially it's
that's Community share of the swept
um there that Community share of the 363
million is the way to think about it and
so for Albany their share of the 363
million or um that essential uh rate of
A1 12 it's an equalized rate um uh um we
can go into the Weeds about why you
don't pay A1 12 you pay something else
because you don't pay an equalized rate
you pay an actual tax rate um we don't
need to go in that right now but um uh
um Alban share of that 363 million is
241 K so we look at the cost of
inadequate education for Albany it's
360k uh um we need to pay uh we know
that they have swept of 241k going
straight from their tax collector to
their uh uh local Treasurer and then to
their school district so we know the
Albany school district has 241k raised
from swept and so we're going to cut
them a check for about 120,000 because
if we cut them a check for 120,000 which
sometimes we called ad adequacy grants
we call it adequacy I call it State cash
because it's literally cash from the
state to the district so if we cut them
a check for 120k plus we know they're
getting 241k from their swept we know
that they're going to have
360k in funding to provide an adequate
education as defined by the
state um same is true for Allenstown
Allenstown their swept revenue is
638k um but their cost of inadequate
education is 2.9 so now we need to cut
them a check of uh 2 .2 million is to
bring them up to the cost of an adequate
education um the one difference here is
when we talk about excess swept Alton is
an excess swept community and so when we
do the cost of inadequate education we
look at all the students in Alton and we
tally that up we get a cost of
inadequate education of 2.7 million when
we look at their swept it's 4.1 million
four really 4.2
million that swept all of that 4.2
million goes to Alton so it goes from
the Alton tax collector uh Alton tax
collector collects it and then sends it
to the Alton School District
um uh we don't need to cut a state check
for Alton because we know they're
getting $4.2 million and we know that
$4.2 million covers the 2.7 million so
they have uh anade enough to cover an
adequate education why it's called
excess swept is because it's above the
cost of an adequate education and so uh
there's litigation it's in the Supreme
Court right now that's saying that Pol
State policy that Alton holds on to that
4.2 million and sends it to their school
district that um uh a superior court
judge ruled that that state policy is
unconstitutional um uh uh certainly uh
there's indiv certainly uh there's
litigation there's parties that disagree
you there's we're not we can't I think
it's not helpful to debate whether
that's the correct decision by the judge
or not um that is the Supreme right now
is in the Supreme Court hands um so the
Supreme Court's going to decide if that
is the correct policy of this
interpretation of the
Constitution if they do say yes the
Superior Court ruled
correctly then at some point the Supreme
Court would direct Dr to start
collecting that excess swept so they
would direct Dr in some way or some
fashion if this is the what the order
determines that um um that extra uh uh
let's see what 1 Point uh 1.5 million or
so I have it on this sheet yeah 1.4
million that extra 1.4 million now needs
to go to the state and that Al Alton is
not able to hold on to that again we
don't know what the order is going to be
uh it could come out right as you're
finishing your budget who knows um it it
it's maybe might might come out during
the Senate phase who knows um but I want
you to be aware of that issue because it
might come out right as you're right as
you're trying to wrap up your work um um
and we're going to go into more details
about the uh how the mechanics of that
is going to work um
if if it does happen representative Happ
and Phillips thank you Mr chair thank
you um for answering this question I'm
not sure everybody on the committee
knows the origin of the $363 million
Value First swept across the state could
you give us kind of like a synopsis of
where that value yeah I don't have the
whole history uh memorized but
essentially um swept was enacted in the
90s late 90s um at one point it was a
rate so the rate was frozen and if
property values grew the revenue and the
rate was frozen and property values grew
the more money would come in um then I
believe at some point maybe it was the
mid 2000s they decided to freeze the
dollar amount so now if property values
grew and the dollar amount was frozen
then the rate would decrease so for the
past several years decades plus um the
revenue has been frozen to 363 uh 36 uh
uh three the property values have been
growing and the rate has been
decreasing um the history of that is I
think around the time when they made
that change it was the rate was bringing
in 363 so I think they just froze it to
what it was currently funding um good
question representative
wer I think that was the money that was
the big energy producers like seab Brook
they had a lot of money so it was kind
of equalizing it by putting it all in
one thing and and letting the state tax
it um basically that was that was where
the the amount came from but
if if they have
17 million or something excess in
Statewide education property tax what I
would ask Mr landrian is if he could
look up and see what other Revenue they
collect from the state let's say the
highway block grant Aid and the meals
and rooms tax and all these other things
that all the towns get a share
of and without adding a bunch of people
to the employment we already have the Dr
has a municipal group that goes around
and sets the tax rate in each town they
could also say okay this 1.7 million
will become a
credit
against meals and rooms
distribution uh Highway block grant or
whatever so that I would call it rather
than a Statewide property tax a
Statewide balancing tax
so that we wouldn't hear the crying oh
you took this money away from our town
to give it to another town well it' be
so complicated nobody'd be able to
figure it out which is you don't want it
to be too simple because then they say
you took $9 million away from us or
whatever it was so that way well it it
varied we we gave you credit on this we
gave you credit on that but not
everything cuz not only are we giving
out a billion dollars but we're also
giving out another 20 million and all
these other taxes and this if we took
all the excess in the Statewide
education property tax it might be what
9 million I think we've heard so yeah it
would be easy enough to do credits by
the staff that comes around and sets the
tax rate and then it would all kind of
be
internal and maybe we wouldn't hear as
much lawsuits and crying anyway yeah the
um the Department of Education has
information as far as what Alton
receives and really it's um um or
Prospect mountain or um uh we have
information about uh District funding
but you're right as far as um the LBA
state aid database and Dr would have
more information about what the town
receives um but yeah we have we have
some limited we have some information we
can provide relative to other state aid
um Alton would receive but but yeah
you'd have to um uh dig a little deeper
and Mickey could help out as far as is
that the biggest one or is it uh
Waterville Valley
well I've got this sheet right here the
um this is the state aid so we'll see
we'll see who's the biggest one
here uh rise up there uh mboro mboro is
the biggest um um mboro has U excess
swept of 4.9 million yeah um Ry looks
like it's number two with
3.1 and then uh um a handful and so yeah
Statewide Statewide the total is 28.6
million um and this is
so essentially if that order um
um we can we can dive into while we're
while we're in it let's dive into EXs
swept
um um I think this is this is helpful
yeah that if if there weren't if there
were other taxes that or other
distribution from the state that this
could become a credit then it would it
wouldn't affect even things out um so um
yeah that that that amount Statewide is
28.6 uh there's a lot of some of the
some of the people want to know um you
can look at your see if your Town's an
excess swept Town representative Murray
oh sorry thank you Mr chair uh just for
clarification because perhaps I'm
misunderstanding what representative wer
is suggesting doesn't swept fund have to
be used for educational
purposes so there's uh I always want to
be careful because there's litigation
going on about this um effectively that
is what's happening for almost every
single Community um all of the large
communities on
here there is litigation where um uh if
the swept is so
large that uh um it overfund it f more
than funds what you would even want to
spend on education then you get a
negative local tax rate and so that is
also being litigated whether that is
allowed um in this sheet right here
almost there's a couple of
unincorporated communities
unincorporated communities have
generally negative tax rates um but um
the large EXs swept communities are
taking that excess weep dollars and
they're funding their school districts
with it um so that would be yeah any any
large community on there is they do not
have negative local tax rates um and
they're funding their education like you
said repres
papovich thank you Mr chair and again
thank you for being here I just wanted
to add one more concern that hasn't been
expressed yet which is that if we start
dealing with excess swept where the
municipality does need to send the money
back to the state that will create
significant cash flow issues in towns
because of the nature of the tax
collection process versus the
disbursement for the school district so
something like what chairman wer was
suggesting
I would say the major goal for that is
to eliminate the friction in the system
in terms of a town potentially needing
to take a short-term loan to send the
money to the state only to get that
money from the state a month later all
this movement of cash would be better if
you know if we can find a way to
decrease it it will just increase the
efficiency in the government so you know
those I've been the finance director in
wiam and my God a lot of my stress was
around meeting cash flow and this would
exacerbate cash flow issu is even for a
town like wiam it has nothing to do with
how much money we collect it's again the
timing of when the tax rates are set and
when the money go to the school
basically I have to pay the money to the
school at the new school budget six
months before I start collecting at the
new tax rate so there are a lot of
intricate things in that that would
justify an approach which would decrease
the amount of money moving in two
directions you know at different points
in time thank you and and and just just
just to get into the weeds a little bit
with cash flow
um uh towns and districts always have to
manage their cash flow of course and
really the town is in the driver's seat
um districts also have to manage their
cash flow as well of course um but the
town and districts are working together
on what is the dispersement schedule of
the money they're raising through taxes
which is the primary source uh um that
funds school districts and they're
sending it to the school
district um and so that's in
dispersements and I've I've seen exess
web legislation that um you can either
do a lump sum um or you can do
dispersements um but cash flow is
definitely a consideration in in either
one of those uh
scenarios
so want to go through this handout
um this one is just a hypothetical
walkthrough of how excess swept would
work if it was uh sorry if XS swept was
remitted to the state this is a
hypothetical walkthrough of how it would
impact a
community so C under current law all
excess swept is retained so if we have
under this hypothetical scenario say we
have a school budget of $2 million $1
million is local education property
taxes $1 million is all swept and um
let's say they retain excess swept of
250k um so under current law it doesn't
matter if it's EXs or not EXs swept they
retain all of it so essentially there's
a very simplistic model here but um $2
million budget half local funded half
state funded uh via
swept um what would happen if overnight
excess swept was remitted to the state
essentially and we controlled so they
did not change their budget in any way
kept their budget flat and what
if um uh no other Revenue Source came in
so again it's a very simplistic model
here but if they had a $2 million budget
and EXs swept had to be remitted to the
state um that community would continue
to pay the $1 million in swept that they
were paying all along the only
difference is is now they don't get to
keep
250k and so um um that 250k now goes to
the state now if they want to continue
to fund their school at $2 million $2
million in a budget um their local
property taxes would have to increase by
250k so now if they took 250k out of
their budget that wouldn't be the case
um but that's the Assumption in this in
this sort of simple model we're holding
here um the reason why I'm mapping this
out is because it can get it is
true that the ex and and I've heard
people talk about this multiple people
talk about this and it is true it is
true that you would be paying your EXs
weep to the state and then you would
also have to Le raise Pro local property
taxes at the same time to keep yeah so
that is true that you're doing two
things at once however it's important to
remember the actual Financial harm
you're receiving as an XS web Community
is only when the state decides you don't
get to keep your excess swept so you
feel the financial harm once even though
there's these multiple transactions
taking place where you're paying the
state you're raising your local property
taxes but um when you see an analysis
and it's going to get tricky um as as
this as you dive into this issue and
receive more may potentially receive
some bills from Ed funding um it's going
to get complicated but um whenever
you're seeing what is the excess
swept um um you might intuitively think
I need to double that to measure my
financial harm but that's not what you
should be doing you should be looking at
um um you should be looking at the
excess swept and go okay if I'm an
excess swept community and this becomes
the law via uh state law via uh uh court
order Etc um whatever is the excess
swept that is the financial harm um
again we're assuming controlling for a
lot of variables here but that's the
correct measurement even though when you
walk through the situation it can get a
little technical as far as um you first
you got to pay the state then you got to
pay your local school um so um anyways
any questions about
that representative Murray thank you um
I'm can you expl I thought you said they
would this is something that only
experience once wouldn't it be once a
year yes yeah okay thank you yeah no no
no uh yeah yeah yeah yeah it would be it
would be once a year but um uh what what
talking this over and I think Mickey and
I were also scratching our heads because
we heard someone say you'd have to pay
it twice
and it's true that the transaction's
occurring in multiple different methods
but your financial harm is measured
once thank you again can I just you know
follow up so um one way of looking at
this um you know from I guess my
perspective where I where I live um
you're
um asking school districts either to
raise their taxes or to reduce the level
of Education that they're providing
their students that would be that's the
effect of if you yeah you you Curr Curr
L pay your swept if you don't get to
keep all of it then the school
district's taxes are going to go up or
if you reduce your budget then the taxes
uh local taxes would not go up so you're
dis
disincentivizing school districts from
maintaining their
education uh um yeah you're you're
there's Financial harm experienced um
and then there's only two ways to deal
with financial har well there's a couple
different ways to deal with financial
harm you find other Revenue uh or you
cut your budget um and that's that's the
reality and that's true with with with
all the school funding aspects represent
papovich thank you I just wanted to
build on what my colleague was saying
and point out that for every dollar that
a donor town is harmed by there is a
receiver town that benefits so at the
state level whether we retain access web
or not is a zero sum game at the end of
the day all that money goes toward
educating kids somewhere but we are
essentially taking from communities and
giving to others the ones we take from
suffer Financial harm the ones we give
to suffer you know in injoy financial
benefits and again it's a zero sum game
game whether we redistribute swept or
not so just just to make sure we are all
on the same page on this yes there is
concern for the towns that are harm but
that state policy should be balanced by
the fact other towns benefits so yeah
all I can say about the Rand order is if
um there's uh this get more complicated
because you can talk about what are you
going to do with the $28 million um the
Rand order just would say collect the
$28 million it wouldn't tell you how to
spend it necessarily
um uh yes repr Kelly thank you how does
how does that affect a school district a
multiple Town district oh uh like a
Cooperative yeah uh good question um so
um adequacy is cooperatives are unique
um inadequacy and swept is somewhat
unique how it deals with um Cooperative
school districts so um a Cooperative
School District so I don't know if do
you have an
example karge we'll use karge as an
example is that seven towns yeah okay
seven towns um so the way cure Sarge
works is essentially they have a budget
for the curge school district um cure
Serge is nice and simple it's not a
split District um John Stark can get uh
cork but um uh cure Serge seven towns
make up the uh seven Town School
District so karge has a budget that
let's say that budget is $30
million um that's their Appropriations
that they would like to do to fund a
cure Sarge School District then there's
Revenue that is shared among the seven
towns so special education Aid title
funding lot of any tuition Revenue
coming in there's a bunch of Revenue
that they would share so essentially you
have $30 million let's say you've shared
revenue of $10 million so now they've
got that $30 million liability is now a
20 $ million liability because they've
all shared that $10 million then what
karge does um um is they a portion out
that $20 million liability between those
seven towns and I don't know if C are
just half EV half ADM whatever their
formula is they're going to share that
that $2 million liability among those
seven towns then before those seven
towns get a tax bill their adequacy and
swept as shown up on this mun sheet is
going to directly credit their tax
liability so if um uh New London has a
really favorable formula they're going
to get all the financial benefits of
having a favorable formula if um is it
Wilmont Wilmont doesn't they're not
going to receive the financial benefits
so each municipality doesn't share their
adequacy Grant with their peers within
the Cooperative so you've got a $30
million budget let's say $10 million
shared Revenue you apportion out based
on whatever the agreed upon
apportionment formula is and then you
credit the adequacy and swept grant for
each community so um that's how that
works so whatever whatever your town is
that receives this grant essentially
it's your Grant it's not shared among
your peers but your title funding and
other funding is shared among your peers
and that's just how cooperatives
work any questions about
swept okay
um so so we we stopped we stopped there
on where the swept is on the uh adequacy
spreadsheet um now we're going into the
extraordinary needs Grant so for the
form for Alton for EXs web communities
the formula is essentially done um Alton
is is um uh but but we'll we'll keep
going for Albany and Allenstown so the
next part of the formula is the
extraordinary needs Grant so this grant
is looking at the equalized valuation
per fnr pupil and so it's property over
poverty essentially and it's becoming a
metric and so if you have a lot of
property in your numerator and not a lot
of poverty not a lot of fnr students in
your denominator um you would have a
really high number and so for Allenstown
even though Allenstown not Allenstown
Alton has um a relatively High fnr
population looks like 20% so a little
bit below State average um they do have
a lot of property so when we do the
property over poverty um the number is
36.4 million for
Alton but if you look at for Albany and
Allenstown um it's much lower and so the
way this grant works is if your evf FRP
that metric property over poverty if
it's higher than 6.86 6 million you
don't get the grant now if it's under
1.6 64 million um meaning you have
either low property or high poverty or
both or some sort of uh your relation
between those two metrics is really low
produces a low number um which is true
for Allenstown um um if that number is
under 1. .6 million you get an equalized
valuation uh um you get an um
extraordinary needs Grant of 11,500 for
each fnr pupil um So currently under
this metric under this estimate no one
is entitled to that 11,500 per fnr pupil
um uh Berlin is close but they don't hit
it I think claremont's pretty close um
Allenstown somewhat close as
well um um so instead you get a number
between 11,500 and zero depending on
where you slide between 1.66 4 million
and the 6.86 million of EV uh FRP
measurement so for Albany um they barely
sort of squeak in um their evrp is 6.7
million uh so they're getting a really
small Grant per each fnr student I don't
know what the number is uh it's probably
a few dollars um because they're really
close to almost not being eligible
because they're really close to that
6866 Million number so um they're
granted their extraordinary needs Grant
is
8,557 um well it's got to be more than a
few dollars it's got to be because it's
produced 8,500 off 33 students but um um
they're close to they're close to not
being eligible um Allenstown um is on
the lower end so they're going to get a
larger Grant um so at that $2.6 million
um if you took that 1.9 and divided it
by 216 I can't do it in my head but you
would get what their extraordinary needs
Grant per pupil is
um so they're going to get a higher
amount than Albany and so that's the
extraordinary needs Grant it's targeted
for communities that have high po uh
High poverty and high low property um as
measured together as a ratio essentially
um this grant in fiscal year 26 the max
amount is now
11,500 um in fiscal year 25 it was
8,670 so in state law it got a boost uh
uh so a lot of communities did see a big
boost in this number um uh under the
extraordinary needs Grant before I keep
going any extraordinary needs Grant
questions okay so that is targeted Aid
uh that keeps going so Alban and
Allenstown get it Al Alton does not
because they're over the
metric the next Grant is the hold
harmless Grant so the way fiscal year 20
uh6 works is whatever the hold harmless
Grant in 25 was it's is going to be your
hold harmless Grant in 26 however it's
going to be 80% of
that so the way fiscal year 25 in way
fiscal 24 worked was essentially we ran
the formula as you as you see it and if
whatever we ran for the formula was less
than 104% of the fiscal year 24 estimate
that we made prior to the budget
changing you were guaranteed to receive
at least that much State cash really um
so that's how the hold harmless worked
in 24 and 25 so a lot of communities if
you look at your 24 25 grant if you're a
hold harmless Community you just
received the same money in 25 as you did
in 24 um because you were basically held
harmless um even though the formula was
not working out in FA not working out in
your favor um um it was not working as
well as it did under the old formula
before major changes were made in fiscal
year 24 um it was not working out better
for you and the reason why you're a hold
harmless Community is likely because the
change in fiscal year 24
was base Aid was increased fnr
differential Aid was increased and the
extraordinary needs Grant was increased
dramatically um but at the same time
stabilization grants went away and
stabilization grants is a hold harmless
Grant from 2012 so back in 2011 they
were making changes to the formula for
2012 and it was going to result in some
communities receiving less money in 2012
than they did in 2011 and so what the
state decided to do was spend $158
million to sure that no Community
received less money in 2012 than they
did in
2011 and that was called stabilization
grants there's a long history of
stabilization grants um they existed um
uh they existed untouched for um several
years until 2017 there was efforts to
reduce them um then in 2020 they were
fully
restored now in 20 in 2024 they were
taken away immediately taken away uh
completely but a lot of different other
boosts were given to the formula um so
when you factor in all the other boost
in the formula um uh uh that helped out
a lot of communities some communities
were not fully made hold by the loss and
stabilization so essentially the new
stabilization which we called hold
harmless is now $59
million so
that's yeah a lot lot cheaper than
158 any questions about hold harmless y
repres papich thank you I just wanted to
state that it's not cheaper overall it's
cheaper as that sole element of the
formula because at the end of the day we
pumped money in a bunch of different
other parts of the formula and overall
last budget cycle we increased overall
education spending by 193 million with
population you know student population
dropping so absolutely agreed that one
element of the formula was
reduced fortunately but there were
plenty of others that um made it a very
positive gain overall that that's
correct above and beyond existing state
aid went up substantially during that
same year in which the hold harmless was
was put into effect um it is very common
hold harmless is um they exist obviously
in New Hampshire other state formulas
use hold harmless it's a very common
Tool uh of course it's it's no one likes
to have their funding reduced so um uh
hold harmless hold armless is are you
see them in other states as well uh uh
usually a policy objective is to keep it
as low as possible so that's that's uh
um something people aim for so uh um
yeah whenever you see a hold harmless
it's sometimes it's it's considered is
the formula working or not um a way to
think about it represent of H Phelps
thank you Mr chair I'm just wondering
Mark um can you remind me how long the
tail is for the hold harmless grants
good question um so um yeah the hold
harmless is now uh sort of set in stone
and determined in 25 this fiscal year
right now um the data is going to shift
a little bit well we've been talking
with some school districts tinkering
with the data just a tiny bit a student
here or there um uh but once we finalize
the fiscal year 25 adequacy which will
be the April 1 payment um that's now the
hold harmless grant that is Frozen um
right now we estimated to be 59 million
it's going to stay around that amount um
then in fiscal year 26 we're reducing it
by 20% in FIS so it's 80 going to be 80%
of that 25 number fiscal year 27 it's
going to be 80% of that number then in
fiscal year 28 it's going to be 60% and
so it's going to reduce essentially it
last for 10 years so uh um every two
years there's a 20% reduction so it's
going to last uh uh the first reduction
is in fiscal year 26 and after we finish
the 10-year period the hold harmless
Grant will be
zero so last it will slowly decrease
over that period by 20% each uh every
other
year and uh uh um so we've been NH has
been going out and talking to
communities and letting them know that
they have a hold harmless Grant and
letting them know that it's going to go
away um so that they can prepare for
that um that's the that's the end of the
formula so essentially you do cost of in
adequate education back out swept that
gets you we call the preliminary Grant
sometimes that gets you an amount um add
extraordinary needs Grant ads hold
harmless Grant um uh if you're eligible
for that that gets you your adequacy
Grant so that's that second to last
column is the adequacy grant it's
essentially the state cash from the
state um but then when we talk about
school funding we combined adequacy and
swept so that's the last column so
that's that billion doll 80 million it's
all state cash and it's all
swept so that's it for adequacy um
excess swept conversations we also have
the packet is there anything
else to discuss relative to school
Finance or adequacy
got a brilliant group I guess we'll just
keep going all
right oh yeah um I'll just quickly go
through the packet um kayin recommended
this
um there's actually a a few kind of neat
things uh kind a few kind of neat things
I want to show you in here so um the
first one is the fiscal year 25 26 27
forecast can you just mention page
you're you're in the ucation funding
orientation correct yes funding
orientation could just mention page
numbers as you go yep um so page two is
basically the education trust fund um
estimates uh currently um for what we
think you're going to be working with um
uh uh U these are numbers numbers to of
course on February uh February 15th
you're going to receive a you're going
to receive the budget from the governor
um so you have different numbers to work
with potentially depending on uh um um
depending what the what the governor
presents um but these are these are
estimates for fiscal year 25 26
27 um for the education trust fund and
the programs and we're going to be
talking about um the the biggest program
of course is District adequacy um uh
we're going to talk about charter
schools in a second
efas EA phas out um multiple other
programs that are funded by the
education trust fund
and the building Aid there just be clear
is detail what you show for 26 and
27 uh for sorry what was the question bu
um the building Aid you show in 26 and
27 just represents the tail correct this
this this this number right here assumes
no new building Aid projects and that's
just the tail liability that you'd have
to pay does everybody understand that
want to understand that no why don't you
explain that
oh oh okay right never mind uh and the
tail almost is going away so it's it's
getting close it's been going on for a
while so I'm getting close to the it's
getting smaller each year
um uh uh yeah you talk about building
Aid later uh page three this is a pie
chart um you don't have the official act
for out the annual comprehensive
financial report um this is just a pie
chart of the education trust fund
Revenue it's un audited uh fiscal year
um uh for you to sort of just see that
uh business profits tax it was pretty
interesting I looked at this
historically business Enterprise tax
used to be a much larger uh piece of the
pie I think it was like 11% of just a
few years ago um so now uh uh um uh
business profits tax is a larger piece
of the pie um Statewide education
property tax is a piece of the pie and
that's um the mechanics of swept is it's
a it's a journal entury so the way to
see it the way you're seeing it on the
Aur and in the state financials is
although um no money left a district
under current law no money left a
district and was sent to the state we
know um that that money was assessed by
taxpayers uh uh assessed against
taxpayers and we know that District sent
we know that town Town Tax Collectors
sent it to their school district so the
state is recording on our books is a
journal entry that 363 363 million was
raised so we'll book that as Revenue
even though no cash came into our bank
and then we booked $363 million went out
from the state and so sometimes it can
get a little confusing when you're
reading a fiscal note what what's going
on with the swep it's basically
accounting it's just a journal entry um
obviously if if the Rand order comes out
whatever may happen if EXs weep becomes
the policy of the state going to change
things a little bit that uh uh but still
there's going to be still going to be
just a a journal ENT uh for the most
part um I always get this uh you might
get this from from your voters um they
always talk about Lottery um I get the
question all the time hey doesn't didn't
Lottery solve school funding didn't
bring in all the so Lottery Lottery
lottery does great for us uh 177% of the
education trust fund it's really
performing super well with 200 million
uh but you know sometimes you'll talk to
someone and they they think it funds the
full billion it does not um um and then
there's other some some other Revenue
sources that come into the education
trust
fund um this documents page page four
it's a little cut off at the bottom this
document's already pretty outdated this
is just an LBA Surplus statement um
throughout the month of March Mickey is
going to be running a lot of these for
you um and just keep keeping you uh
keeping tabs of the education trust fund
um uh and you'll get Revenue numbers um
coming out monthly that are going to
change the Dynamics of this um if the
revenue numbers uh don't hit um so that
is an education trust fund Surplus
statement hang on second
mark so like Mark said this document
will end up looking pretty familiar to
you as we work through this session
we'll have one like this for also the
highway fund and the fishing game fund
it's a surplus statement we call it so
this is a good big picture of the
education trust fund especially for the
new members you can see all the revenue
up top all the programs that are funded
on down below so we will get those
Revenue estimates from house Ways and
Means at some point hopefully within the
next month um if not hopefully on the
sooner end and then all the
Appropriations down below those are up
to this committee to determine how much
you want to fund each program at uh what
level you could some of the attorney
members will recall it the education
trust fund never used to be this
widespread for the number of programs it
covers it used to Simply Be adequacy
charter school adequacy and the low and
moderate um income tax relief program at
Dr it's been expanded quite a bit
because there was a lot of resources in
the education trust fund but all of this
is the uh prerogative of this committee
how you want to fund all these moving
forward in your budget package so I just
wanted to make sure everyone understood
this is an important document you'll see
reoccurring in this committee for the
next several
weeks does that make sense
everybody um this as a result of what
the Senate did it didn't have all these
things listed when it left us two years
ago two years if you recall the the
house passed budget I don't want to
misspeak I think it it it took out a ton
of the programs and put put them on the
general funds and switch some of the
allocations of the uh business tax
revenue to be mostly in the general fund
the Senate did unwind those changes in
its proposed budget um and that
ultimately is what ended up passing so
that that is uh correct what
representative o just
described um yeah that's so that's the
Surplus statement um page five is
basically the one pager on adequacy you
just you you just got that
presentation um page six through um the
few next Pages um it shows you um fiscal
year 25 compared to fiscal year 26 I've
been sharing this information with the
districts because I want districts to
know if their funding is their if their
funding is decreasing and it's likely
caused to the hold harmless going away I
wanted them to be aware um so they can
prepare for that um but the way you'll
always rece going forward um the way
you'll always receive analysis is it's
always going to be what is current law
so mean you do nothing and then what is
the proposed policy so you'll be seeing
that in fiscal notes you've already been
seeing that in fiscal notes but any
analysis moving forward that's the
standard at which we do analysis on this
um this is just unique analysis so don't
expect to receive this analysis moving
forward you'll always see proposed
policy versus current
law um page 12 uh is the adequacy
history document um it's got some of the
ch ches throughout the years um adequacy
had changed pretty much for five
straight years it changed every year um
uh fiscal year 25 almost no change
except for that home education piece um
but I'm not going to count it I'm going
to count it as a year without change um
uh uh I'll guess I'll get into the I
don't know if I want to get into the
weeds with this but uh um you can change
adequacy anytime you want via state law
however if you ever change the districts
are right now working on their 26 budget
so if you change adequacy they're not
going to be able to adapt their budgets
um in any way to it they have processes
in place to do special district meetings
however um um if you change adequacy
every single year it's going to it's
just a revenue change for the district
um just something to be mindful of
sometimes uh previous committees have
decided to always change it in the the
year give them one year to adjust to it
um um you can you you under State law
can change it whenever you want
uh but that's just something to to think
about representative wer the problem
with what the Senate did putting all
these things into adequacy was that we
ended up with 129 million in Surplus
education trust fund that couldn't be
used anywhere else in the second year
when there were other things that we
would have liked to have funded but the
error of the Senate and putting all this
stuff and and adequacy meant that
everything was tied up in education
trust funds so I don't think we want to
repeat that
again um page 13 is just a breakdown of
fiscal year 24 and 20 2020 and this is
um uh you can look at the expenditure
side of it um to see um where there's
growth and expenditures are where the
expenditures are taking place um we're
using 2020 as sort of the pre-co year um
um even though the last couple months
were Co impacted uh fiscal year 24
obviously the current the latest data we
have um only thing pointing out is
there's a lot of federal money that went
out to school districts that money is in
the process of expiring but you'll see
that in the data um all the additional
Federal money has increased expenditures
for school districts because they
received the money spending the money um
is there a reason new Founders excluded
um they did not provide a financial
report uh it's a long story but okay
they had
yeah um hopefully we'll get that we'll
get that soon
um page 14
uh um this is looking at 23
24 uh page 15 is um cost per pupil this
is something we publish on our website
you hear talked about a lot um important
to know that cost per pupil it's current
expenditures so it doesn't include debt
Ser uh Debt Service doesn't include
Capital expenditures it's current
operating expenditures there are some
other exclusions in there um and it's
over the students being educated in that
school so Albany does not educate any
students so they don't have a cost per
pupil because this is meant to measure
the cost of educating a student at a
school that you're operating and Albany
doesn't operate a school um so cost per
people just a common common data point
or metric you'll see in the in the area
in school Finance
space um page 19 is equalize valuation
over
admr um if you ever hear the term Fiscal
Capac capacity to disparity Aid instead
of looking at property values over um
fnr students uh um fysal capacity
disparity Aid is a Formula an a concept
that has existed in the state for a
while now and when um um gets discussed
a lot and that's the concept of not
focusing on fnr students but focusing on
all property over all students um and so
that's measured as equalized valuation
per pupil and so um you might hear that
um well The house's The house's passed
bills recently that the Senate um uh did
not agree with um relative to that
concept all right page page 26 is my my
favorite data
point a lot of you uh like to look at
your tax rate and you have a lot of
feelings about your tax rate um wherever
they may be but you always and then you
want to look at your neighbor's tax rate
and so you can't do that accurately you
can't look at your tax rate and your
neighbor's neighbor meaning um uh a
neighboring town and say oh man that
Town's got it that Town's got it so nice
they might have it nice but you you you
don't want to look at the tax rate that
they pay because that is based on the
assessed valuation and you don't know
how that Town's assessing practice is so
you want to look at an equalized tax
rate so this controls that if you had
one town that was assessing every year
it would make it look like the property
well the properties would be keeping up
with market value and therefore the tax
rate would be pretty low um but if you
had a town that was really slow to
assess and they weren't assessing that
often um but costs were going up um the
tax rate would look really high and so
you would think that Community is paying
more than you but really they're just
not assessing as often so the tax rate
looks really high because they're slow
to assess and then one Community the tax
rate may think you have a really low tax
rate but really you're just assessing so
much and so the only way to control or
the best way to control for that is to
look at an equalized tax rate and so
this provides a more apples to apples
comparison there's so much that goes
into taxes Revenue expenditures but when
you can control for assessing practices
you can actually see you know if you're
getting a good deal to to some extent um
really you're only controlling for
assessing practices but that's the way
to that's the way to analyze um uh your
tax rate and compared to your peers um
looking at that equalized
rate okay we're moving along here uh
page 32 is just um uh enrollment
participation by um uh all the different
entities that exist so we have
non-public enrollment um we talked about
it head orientation um the home
Education data is not super reliable um
uh the district Public School data it
comes in we have something called a sid
that is basically it's like a student
social security number essentially it's
a unique number that comes in for each
student so um we have data controls on
the student data that's coming in to
make sure they're not duplicating a
student
uh because they have this unique
identifier um we have data controls for
Charter Schools we have data controls
for U EFA students the sasset is the
data control um the other aspects are
surveys and so they're less controlled
data collections um it's the data we
have so it's the data you kind of have
to use because there's no other data
that I can provide you um but um um this
is where you can look at basically where
the students are being educated um with
most most of the students being in the
district system so
there seems to be quite a jumping around
like from 15 16 then drops down
dramatically and then starts to spike
back up again it can you especially the
1516 and 16117 is there a reason for
that I'm look at the total number down
there 6 6,000 down to 2700 yeah so um
the way thato students reported to the
Department of Education changed so um
home schoolers used have to register
since I've been I wasn't there I wasn't
working time but all homeschoolers used
to have to register with the state or
their local District annually so there
was more reporting requirements and the
N was Chang so students only need to
register in their lifetime so we could
stop reporting stop collecting that
information the department that chose to
at least collect from the schools the
number of new registrants every year so
the number that we're reporting right
now is actually the number of new
registers for getting every year rather
than the number of children that are
annually access schools
okay so these numbers only represent new
people coming in at that to our knowled
so like Mark said use the data with a
grain of assault because there are still
many parents that register every single
year and the district might not know
that also if a district child to move
around there's ambiguity whether they
need to register each district they live
in they might register once in their
educational career they might be
registering every year there's still
probably some confusion with um
students receiving EFA whether they need
to register with their discri or not so
we do know that at times students have
tried to register with their District
even though that's not required if
you're
accram and because we don't have any
unque student data as Mark just
mentioned we can't really do any
reconciliation on that thank you in in a
concept in education um it's it's it's
somewhat intuitive kids need to go to
school um uh or kids need to get an
education um the way just an area that
it's helpful to think about this is It's
called the compulsory attendance law and
so students need to be in an educational
system once they turn six so they need
to either be in their District school a
public charter school a non-public
school an home education program or an
EFA program so those are all the
different ways in which a student can
receive an education that's compliant
with state law in New Hampshire um and
so uh some of those students are home
educated non-public
Etc um
lastly uh this is just Federal funding
on page 33 and
that's that's uh allocations out there
uh these are kind of our standard
allocations so they don't include all
the additional covid money um that's um
the state has been spending over the
past few years um it was allocated out
you know multiple years ago um that is
federal funding that's the packet
so any questions representative muray
thank you again uh just so I'm really
clear on the part of the packet that has
you know 300 Pages uh the were um so so
I say page 30 pick you know pick any of
them the towns that are listed in the I
guess the fourth column from the left
those are the towns that are included in
the Cooperative District right and so a
place like Ry sends their students to
Portsmouth for high school that's cont
that's treated as tuition yes thank you
just yep and weal yeah there's a lot of
different ways to structure your school
you can can be a standalone School
District that doesn't operate a school
or you can be um um yeah you can be a
town that's part of a Cooperative um
yeah multiple multiple different
complexities we can get into that if
we'd like to but um maybe save it for
another
day all right thank you so before you go
so just this that that Federal
page it's about 140 million dollar a
year roughly that would be getting this
year in federal aid is that what how to
read that yep um yes um with the biggest
one being um uh uh the title programs
which is up top um that's our largest
largest funding source and then idea
which is the special education grants to
schools um that's the second largest or
that's actually is the largest um
funding source in the federal
funding thank you so that's what the
grants the states there under subtotal
that's the
idea um yep yep special education grants
yeah okay thank you
what
welcome do you want me to take you
through those Federal programs real
quick and tell you what each one does
sure which since we're here um just back
to that packet what page was that one on
last page it's the last page
33 this may be inform useful information
going forward so um because there's
obviously a lot of conversations about
what's going to happen with the federal
money and whatnot so the the bulk of the
federal money that's coming into
education in New Hampshire are these
programs right here um these sorry both
of the K12 education funding um there's
plenty of higher edit funding and other
funding um but so on the first line um
that you have you have title one so
everybody knows the term title one but
it's helping uh educationally
disadvantage students so typically
students um in poverty the is a Formula
that's in federal law that provides
additional funds based on your free and
reduced lunch percentages and your total
overall enrollments but it's heavily
weighted on
um title or your free and reduced lunch
percentages there's also some set as
sides in that for low performing schools
so the bottom five% of schools are known
as CSI schools comprehensive support and
Improvement schools um and so there's a
set aside in that that goes to those
schools um migrant is exactly what it
looks like it's um funding that is
provided to provide educational supports
for migrant students in the state
neglected and delinquent is students
there is funding that helps students in
um like group homes in New Hampshire
there's also a set aside in title one
that supports those kids too um
supporting infe effective instructional
state grants that's known as title back
to the migrant line who gets included
there um so students that are considered
migrant students in the state and the
definition I think is you have to be
working on agricultural programs um and
these are typically students that are
working on farms we see a lot of them um
or their parents are working on farms
like at apple orchards and whatnot in
the fall and so they're more transient
population and I believe these funds can
be used providing uh to tutoring
Services directly to the students where
they are living and do you track them by
year in terms of numbers we do yes and
can we get that information um we can
yes
thanks um so the next one is supporting
effective instruction so that's known as
title 2A that's a term that we all call
it it's essentially professional
development funding for school that are
used to support teachers in schools it
can be used um for some class size
reduction as well but the majority of it
is instructional support or professional
development 21st Century Learning
Centers is before in after school
programs again um it's heavily weighted
on free and reduced lunch numbers um
State assessments is um exactly um what
we um what it sounds like it provides
supports for the state assessment
required under
Esa Rural and low-income schools is uh
funding that is dispersed to rural or
low income schools around the state it
is um very flexible as far as the
supports but you can see there's not a
ton of money so it doesn't go very far
um same with the rural School
achievement program that's is known as
reap that actually weirdly doesn't flow
through the Department of Education I
guess one of these the things I should
explain is the majority of this funding
that you see right here is Flowing
directly from the US Department of
Education to the New Hampshire
Department of Education the New
Hampshire Department of Education then
calculates what each district is
entitled to based on a formula that's in
federal law and then disperses those
funds we go ahead we have a pretty
comprehensive Grant management system
and process that we're required to
follow including monthly drawdowns of
funding we review to make sure that
activities that schools are spending the
funding on are allowable under these
different grants and then we have um a
lot of liance requirements around these
grants so just to make sure I understand
this because I was going through some of
these um
rsas if you look at the State Board of
Education rsas they make reference to
the fact that that's where the federal
all the federal funding flows into some
account is that the same thing as you're
saying the Department of Education or is
it really another something else going
on so one of my other bills I've been
very passionate about over the years is
Rec codifying the education laws um
because there are a lot of areas where
um the thing like Commissioner of
education and Department of Education or
Department of Education and State Board
of Education are used
interchangeably um and there's
definitely a lack of clarity and this
that's one of those things so um these
all of these grants right here with
exception of the reef one the rural
School achievement program all has a
separate accounting unit in the
department of education budget and
you're seeing those funds and those will
be part of our bigger overall budget so
when you see that we have I think it's
like two or three 00 million of federal
funding in the department budget that
includes these these monies as well have
you made any progress on
the I know a couple years ago we looked
at try to do the whole thing and and
that was just like out of control have
you made your progress of little bits
and pieces we might like plug in here
and there so I mean we are always
working on different pieces um where we
tried to rewrite say the accountability
law last year we got some push back on
that um we have some other pieces of
data on like the data comprehensive
piece that we should do those are not to
be done in a budget year we don't have
the time to do that in a budget year
there is um a bill once again to allow
the department to do that I think with
division 2 we had actually come up with
a really good plan which was require the
department to release an RFP come to
fiscal with the results of those RSP
that RFP and then fiscal could decide if
they wanted to fund that unfortunately
that's ultimately not what got passed
and there was some other there was
another bill that got killed in in the
Senate and um so it it's uh so just let
it go yeah well no we should still do it
it's it's very important because there's
a lot of questions like that you like
that that you just asked that really do
need to be clarified um I mean and
there's just other sections of law you
know when we're talking about the
student um identifier for example um
there's a section of law that
establishes our um system that we use
for that and then other information that
can be attach that and it's spread
throughout all of those education laws
and it really needs to be put in one
place so we really have a comprehensive
understanding that can be what can be
done with that so and it does require
the legisl it's not something you can do
in rules in most cases uh no it's for
sure the law um the rules would need to
be updated after but it is the the law
is just so maybe next year we can at
least get a little piece of it instead
of trying to shoot for the moon yeah I I
think that would be um a great thing to
talk about
so yes Susan representative D Roy sorry
I'm not so familiar with the grants for
schools does it all go through you or
can the individual schools go for
federal grants as well um so there are
sometimes federal grants that the
federal agency May release that would go
uh that they could apply to directly but
these funds all go through us and
they're required to so we're known as a
flow through agency or an sea a State
Education Agency and in the law that
establishes many of these so the ones
that we're talking about right now are
the every all established in the every
student six leads law it requires the
funding to go to the Sea us and then us
to distribute the money to an Lea the
local Education Agency
so if they go directly to the federal
agencies for Grants the the individual
schools do they report that to you if
they go outside of this program and
there's a grant out there so it would be
reported on the doe2 if it's a federal
expenditure because they're required to
report all expenditures at the school
district level so um another example of
a grant um so the department of energy
recently had grants for school districts
for Energy Efficiency projects and that
doesn't go through us but if a school
district were making those expenditures
they would need to be reported on the
doe 25 to us so when we're looking at
the total spending when you're looking
at local state and other spending all
federal funding and all local spending
regardless of who's giving it to the
school should be reported on the
doe2 um all right so so small rural
education achievement program again so
that's that goes directly to the schools
student academic supports and enrichment
grants that's known as title 4B um that
is really used for Technology support at
schools um English language acquisition
that's uh known as title three those are
for um students that um have limited
English language proficiency um and that
those funds go to support school
districts providing services to those
children homeless children and youth it
is exactly what it sounds like it's to
provide school um support to school
districts that have homeless
children um and then so those are the
esa that every student succeeds act um
Grant grants those were previously known
as No Child Left Behind when it was
reauthorized it was that every student
succeeds act um it is the part of the
larger Elementary and secondary
Education Act um which was the original
Education Act which one was that you
were so all all of the ones I just um
talked about oh okay thank you so
starting toing so then the next thing so
you have the individuals with disability
and Education Act that's known as it
idea um or special education and so
there's three grants um totaling about
60 1 million that New Hampshire is
entitled to um you have the largest
Grant the $56 million Grant and the
preschool Grant the 1.7 those flow
through the Department of Education the
grants for infants and families actually
go through HHS here in New Hampshire
just kind of to kind of delineate that
which does the grants for infants and
families thank you but the rest of that
goes through the dep Department of
Education um and then career and Tech
education grants or otherwise known as
the Carl D Perkins Grant and those are
to provide funding to school districts
that have a career and a tech education
program those are the large federal
grants that are flowing through us there
are other grants that we receive at the
Department of Education um those usually
are federal discretionary grants that we
may apply for directly to the US
Department of Education the one that I
can think of most recently or not most
most recently but one we were successful
in receiving um we received the charter
school Grant the $46 million Charter
School grant that was a discretionary
grant that the Department of Education
applied for we were actually required to
apply for it in state law but there was
no requirement for us to apply for it in
federal law so we applied it and we're
success applied for it and were
successful we've also applied for two
slds student longitudinal Data Systems
grants and those are just supplemental F
funds that help us uh improve our
education reporting
systems so all those you just rattled
off come under the Career and Technical
no no no no those are completely
separate they just so these are the ones
that the Department of Education
typically gets on a very regular basis
that are um because of Federal Acts that
um allocate funding to the state those
this is out of a federal budget this is
not out of the Department of Education
Bud budget so when you're looking at the
department of education budget as a
whole you'll see those other grants but
this right here is just for the purpose
of talking about the formula grants that
so one of the the things that you know
we've been talking about lately in the
news is when you're talking about
formula grants to States um or or sorry
block grants to States instead of
formula grants these are likely the ones
that would become block grants rather
than formula grants so the Career and
Technical education say grants does that
have any relationship to
ccsnh um I do actually believe there's a
set aside that goes to ccsnh um Melissa
white will be here on Wednesday and can
um can you actually write that down um
uh we'll be able to clarify that for you
but I think there is a small set aside
that's supposed to help um tech ed
programs okay and what would the rest of
it be going toward um public schools
that have a career in Tech education
center so like here in conquered we have
the conquered Regional Tech so we have
in New Hampshire we have Regional career
and Tech Education Centers we have our
regional model so high school level high
school level yes yeah K through 12 um
which the state as a whole um determined
was the best way of having career and
Tech education in the 70s um and so that
helps um have higher quality programs
reduces duplication and provides um or
increases Statewide um availability to
students that may live in a more rural
community who that Community itself
couldn't necessarily support a career
and Tech education program so because we
have this Regional tuitional tuition
model it helps um increase access um so
we'll talk about that we have so the
federal funding is specifically to
support the programs and then we have
state funding too called Career and
teched tuition and transportation which
helps those school districts that are
sending those kids to a district that's
not theirs um with supports for the the
transportation costs and the tuition
costs of those KS thank you and I would
see that in the budget yes you'll see
that in the budget thank
you so I just wanted that was just a
kind of brief overview of those federal
funds I know we're getting a lot of
questions about those
so um so next up we're going to talk
about charter schools and Brian Eaton is
going to take over and talk about
charter school funding thank you good
afternoon uh my name is Brian and I also
work in The Bu of school Finance um so
this is a quick packet packet this won't
go uh too long this is just to provide
some insight to how Charters are funded
this is specifically state aid so kayen
just mentioned there's a charter Grant
that's a Federal grant for startup of
Charters this is what we're talking
about is strictly just state aid similar
to what we talked about earlier with
Mark
adequacy so page two might look familiar
so it is a what we call one pager on
Charter Public School funding and so the
the majority of these rates will look
familiar because these are the rates
that are followed for district adequacy
those adequacy rates Mark just mentioned
before there slight variations we'll go
through and describe those so it's very
top bar uh top row there that is the
base adequacy aid for all students based
on ADM calculation throughout the whole
year that is 4 $
4,265
64 and another thing to uh another
different differentiation between this
and adequacy is that this is paid the
year the student isn't so with adequacy
there's one year lag um Charter Aid is
paid the year so we're in fisc year 25
also school year 25 those students are
paid throughout the year in iterations
through four payments they are the
charters are paid the same year the
students
attend next row would be fnr again we
talked about that those are students
eligible for free and reduced lunch
price meals and that is the same rate as
you would see in
adequacy next row is special education
same rate the difference is also with
special education is that it is paid to
the district of responsibility so the
amount of um Aid that would be for us
Char of school for uh for example
students that are identified as special
education attend that Charter School the
aid is actually going to the town those
students reside in and then the town or
district school district would work with
the charter school on um anou or tuition
agreement in order to actually uh work
through if the child's receiving those
Services there they might not be so
that's something that the uh Charter
School in the district or town would
work work together with to coordinate
those services and that is uh in law
because the town responsibility is
responsible for U for coordinating those
Services uh responsible for those
Services special
education next row would be English
language learner again similar to
District adequacy that is uh the rate
also in District adequacy and each one
of those we mentioned earlier increasing
2% each year uh through current
law so that break that breaks down each
Aid component for a charter Aid there's
one additional which is called the
additional Grant um and so it is
different between VX which is the uh
virtual Learning Academy Charter School
and non-vx so for all intented purposes
that can be sort of tacked on to the
base Aid it's an additional Grant rate
for every student that attends that
charter school so on the bottom left
you'll see two blocks one is additional
grant for non VX and then one is for VX
so the non VX would be
$597 n6 VX would be
$2,445 15 so to the right of that you'll
see some gray uh sorry some green blocks
and so you'll see that the additional
Grant uh is for um it the additional
Grant and the base for non-vx would come
to that
9,363 60 figure in the bottom right and
then the base plus the differentiated um
sorry the base and the additional grant
for V would come to $
6,710 79 so it's mostly the same as
District district adequacy the only
difference is being that there's
additional Grant um that taxs on to the
base Aid rate as well as The Slight
differences uh with the special
education that Aid being paid directly
to the U to the town responsibility
District responsibility everything else
all the other rates are paid to the Char
of school directly from the
state any questions on that before
moving
forward
great the next three pages again mostly
just reference documents so this first
one which is page three or five that
would be each charter school which would
you follow on the left side going down
for each row and then the ADM for each
charter school and where they fit into
each one of those categories we just
described whether it's base Aid fnr
special ification elll so this is for
fy4 the last uh fiscal year that we
fully paid out we're currently in FIS 25
so we won't know that until the final
payment um after school ends and so uh
this is FIS 24 and then you'll see those
four um categories that you see similar
to district adequacy and then you'll see
the additional Grant there uh third from
the right uh so it breaks out each one
base fnr special education El and then
the additional Grant as well and it also
breaks out on the very right it shows
the second from the last is the total
grant for students attending Charter
Schools the very right one would be the
actual grant that the the charter
schools receive so it backs out that
special education uh Aid because those
because that's sent to the town District
responsibility
so those are all charter schools in 24
and then uh each one of they're the
grants that you know through state aid
as well as broken down each each
category the next page would be four out
of five that is more of a historical
document just explaining um the rates in
ADM for Charter Schools uh from FY 2017
to 2026 so working left to right is FY
17 to 26 breaks down uh the this first
uh kind of top third of the sheet would
be the rate for each type of ADM so we
have our ADM for kindergarten in grades
1 through 12 which was different at one
point in time now they're the same treat
the same rate and then as you work down
fnr special ucation in Elo Mark
mentioned there was a third grade
reading grant that was discontinued uh
beginning FY
24 and then each one of those additional
grants so that shows the trend and the
differences and increases of each rate
uh from 2017 to 2026
through current law for FY 26 and then
below that the middle uh sort of bar
there would be the adms uh for each one
of those categories throughout those
years again with the percent increase
and the change uh you may see one kind
of outlier one one sticking out would be
fy22 well really fy21 an increase of um
base ADM
963 and that was vlax through pandemic
that was digal enrollment through vlax
um so there's a bump there and then what
shows is a decline in ADM is really just
returning back to normal in a way uh
between fy21 and 22 mostly vac students
receiv receiving the services through
virtual Learning
Academy and then the bottom right or
sorry bottom uh bar there is the total
cost of Charter Aid through each one of
those categories uh through each fiscal
year so the total and then breaking it
down by each one of those categories as
well and the final page again just
mostly reference document would be every
Charter School that is currently open or
has closed since from FY 2007 to uh
currently the fiscal year 25 so working
uh from the top left down be all those
Charter Schools about most of the way
down you'll see uh closed charter
schools so those will include uh charter
schools that were open at one time but
have closed um as of this fiscal year
they are no longer
open and then each one of the adms uh
this is just base ADM uh through each
year and then the very bottom is where
you'll see VX that's their FA time and
full-time equivalent um for students if
there's students that are attending
Charter uh VX part-time but they're also
attending their resident District
fulltime those students are full-time
equivalent um that's based on um credits
and percent complete that VX reports to
us so that's how we calculate to payment
for
them so that's about it like I said
mostly uh this is all reference
documents for Charter Schools um you
know through the years in that very
first document will explain how it's
funded in different categories again
similar to
adequacy so I want to remind the
committee that charter schools are
authorized by the State Board of
Education um they're nonprofits in the
state of New Hampshire and they have a
local Board of nonprofit board members
that oversee the school as opposed to a
traditional Public School District so
that's kind of the difference um and
they provide some but not all of or they
have to follow rather some but not all
of the same requirements that District
public schools have to require so um a
good reminder to as you're working
through legislation if there's something
that you want to impact both charter
schools and District Public Schools you
do need to say both you need to actually
call out charter schools because
otherwise charter schools are exempt if
law does not specifically talk about a
charter
school and one more to add just
particular to funding we've seen a
couple bills come through so far that's
in house um funding education funding
that if you were if a legislator were to
try and in we're proposing a bill to
increase District adequacy the rates
that we just described for Charters are
ref refer as the same rates that are in
District adequacy so uh if you are
changing one it has kind of a trickle
effect uh waterfall effect so uh when
there's rates being changed it will
affect not just District adequacy but
also Charter adequacy as well so in the
rates case we don't need to make that
special we don't have to refer to both
is that no what you're saying unless you
don't want it to impact both it will
automatically impact both so the way it
works so Charter Schools fall under RSA
194b um but that refers back to rsaa 198
which is the quacy law the same for
Education Freedom accounts which we'll
talk about in a
moment representative Dy just a quick
question on um specialized schools like
the Monarch School of New England down
in Rochester how does that work into all
of these numbers because I know you're
funding that as well right um I that's
that's a non-public school so they they
have agreements with the districts so um
the districts paid the nonpublic school
to provide those Services um um if a
District's educating a special education
student they're going to receive special
education differential Aid um if it's a
high cost special education student they
might receive special education normally
known as catastrophic Aid um and so the
district would receive that money but
then they would be paying the Monarch
school okay so thank you yeah so we have
a variety of non-public schools in the
state and some of them are approved just
through the State Board of Education to
provide general education services and
then some of them are an addition to
that approval from the State Board of
Education seek an additional approval
from our special education office then
we'll approve them to provide special
education services and so then if they
are pro being provided funding every go
thing goes through the district the
district um looks at a child's IEP and
says these are the child's disabilities
and I think this non-public school which
is approved can provide those supports
and will place the child there and then
through the placement um the district is
reimbursed through the regular process
and we don't have any direct
reimbursement through the Monarch school
or any other non-public school okay
great thank
you uh representative Murray thank you
I'm just curious and I may have seen
this and forgotten can you just give a
brief breakdown of the schools uh how
many are K through 12 how many focus on
Elementary the Middle School how many
are R the high school I don't have that
today but I can certainly bring that
back for one thank you so
much Mr L Brian can you just let the
committee know how you came up the
fiscal 26 and 27 estimates for Charter
Schools does that assume enrollment
growth new schools coming on board how
were those numbers derived sure great
thank you uh yes so one the easy one
would be uh new schools that are
estimated open FY 26 that would include
our estimates our best guess estimates
working with the school and and maybe K
can describe that better um it does also
include uh like you just mentioned
Trends so between what we currently have
for FY 2025 for enrollment for each
charter school as well as what they uh
reported for fy2 24 uh and that holds
true similar how we treat District uh
estimates as well so our estimates for
FY 26 are using Trends based on
enrollment current year compared to
historical Trends um and then including
uh schools that are to open as well I do
think it's important to remind the
committee too that we have that that
grant that I mentioned that $46 million
grant that Grant is specifically for
opening new and increasing um existing
Charter Schools or expanding sorry
existing charter schools so the
Department of Education is in the tail
end of that Grant meaning that we are
providing funds to groups that would
like to start new Charter Schools
allowable use of funds is a pretty
rigorous process um and then once the
school's open they're not really
entitled to any more startup grants
that's when they go into just the
regular formula um charter schools in a
time where we wouldn't have a grant
there will be less charter schools
opening Rob papich thank you Mr chair
and again thank you for your patience
this afternoon um I asked a similar
question in education funding in regards
to the kids who are taking ESL you know
who are categorized as is English as a
second language I uh wanted to repeat
the question here so everybody's aware
of the discussion right that I'm trying
to understand how many years should a
child be in an ESL program before they
are supposed to know English and no
longer be an ESL kid and um in addition
to what we were talking about a few days
ago I wanted to know if the department
has information indicating how many
years does a kid spend in an ESL program
do you just get totals are you told that
a specific student is in that program
just I I I want to understand what you
guys have and again what you feedback
you can provide on the appropriate
amount of time for a child who comes in
as English as a second language to
become proficient in English and no no
longer require those Services thank you
sure um so we do have um a person of the
Department of Education paid through by
one of those federal grants the English
language learner Grant who specializes
in this area so I can see if they are
available for our presentation on
Wednesday if not I believe Melissa the
director might be able to provide more
information as far as your questions
about the data though um so when we um
collect information on a student a
school will specify if the student is an
English language learner student and
that means um one we will know how
they're uh performing on the English
language learner assessment because
there's an assessment to specifically to
gauge a students's understanding of the
English language and then also if the
student is receiving additional supports
around them being an English language
learner um so we have that information
on the student when we collect that
information but as far as how many years
I I'm I don't have that
information thank you um given that you
guys seem to have that information on
individual student level would it be
possible to have a some analysis not by
individual obviously but you know out of
the kids in the ESL program so many of
them are in the their first year here
some so many of them are in the second
year and so on again if you aggregate it
at the state level there shouldn't be
any privacy concerns and all I'm looking
for is to Total Statewide nothing uh
District
specific thank
you any other Charter stuff before we
switch topics
all right we'll switch to
efas okay one more packet for you
all right last up for today um we're
going to talk about education Freedom
accounts um or efas in other states they
are known as education savings accounts
that's kind of the national terminology
or some states have a voucher type
program but in New Hampshire we call
them education Freedom accounts um so
education Freedom accounts are a um
funding that allows uh parents to
provide or provides funding to parents
to make educational choices for their
children outside of a resident District
school or a public charter school the
way the funding formula works is very
similar to the same way the funding
formula works for the other two programs
we've talked about today so when you
look at page two on your packet um
you're going to see some numbers that
look very familiar um because just like
the charter schools uh the education
Freedom account numbers are based on the
RSA 198 adequacy numbers um and there
are no additional differentials that are
on the education Freedom account program
so the way it works in New Hampshire a
little high level is so the law um which
was passed in hb2 and 2021 um
established the program starting in
fiscal year 22 the program right now is
in its fourth year of operation um and
it provides funds um or requires the
Department of Education to provide the
funds to a scholarship organization and
then the scholarship organization is
required to determine students eligible
for these funds and then distribute
These funds into a digital wallet the
the state law actually requires use of a
digital wallet system that then the
parents can access these funds to pray
for educational expenses associated with
the child um so this means that um the
Department of Education um collects data
from the student from the scholarship
organization in the same way that we do
from traditional Public Schools we
collect student level SD level data um
we do a calculation to see how much that
child um should receive if they should
receive a base amount a free a free and
reduced lunch amount a special education
amount or an English language learner
amount and then it's dispersed four
times throughout the year um to the
scholarship organization the scholarship
organization is allowed to keep up to
10% off the top for administration of
the accounts and the remaining funds go
into the digital wallet so the amounts
that we're talking about today so just
like we talked about before
$426 for every kid is the base amount um
4,200 uh two
$2,392 is the amount for a free and
reduced lunch
$2,184 is a special education amount and
$832 is the amount for um an English
language learner
student and the on that page also you
have the dispersement schedule so we
disperse it throughout the year four
times based on counts just like we do
with um District public schools and
Charter Public
Schools um similar to Charter Schools
EFA accounts are paid in real time too
so remember District Charter district
schools are paid one years and rear
charter schools and education Freedom
accounts are are paid in the current
year so the next page in your packet is
page number three um it is a lot bigger
than this ADM history that you've seen
for the other programs but that's just
because it's very few years that have
been in operation so in 10 more years
the other one's going to be really small
as well um but so you can see the kind
of the trends that we've had so you can
see on line six so the first year of the
program count on October 1st was 1,635
kids the second year is
3,25 the third year 4,211 and then um as
of um this year or our estimate for this
year is
5,852 so those are kind of the numbers
that we have and then we kind of show
you the total dollar amounts so $8
million the first year 14.6 the 2 22 in
fiscal year 24 and this year we're
anticipating the program to be $30
million um these funds are drawn from
the education trust fund as required by
the education Freedom account law and
it's also an allowable use of the
education trust fund under the law that
establishes the education trust
fund the next thing in your packet um is
just the towns and the counts from each
town so um this looks obviously a lot
like the adequacy spreadsheet that you
saw before but the funding does not go
to the town this just represents the
resident town of the
student flip through all those
pages um and that's current year too so
if you look at the very last column we
haven't made the April dispersement yet
so that one that's why that's blank so
is that tracking the amount that's still
going to the town even though the
student is gone no this this is the
amount that's specifically dispersed to
the scholarship Organization for funding
the child's
EFA but next thing in your packet on
page nine is the phase out Grant so the
phase out Grant um when the legislature
established this program wanted to
provide additional supports for school
districts well um fund uh when for one
these a student left a public school
district to take an EFA um and so in the
very first year that a student accesses
the EFA because adequacy is paid one
year in re the school district has 100%
of those adequacy funds still available
to them um we in New Hampshire pay for
the student where they attend the school
we've always been that way so when we're
talking about the adms for um adequacy
that Mark was talking about before those
only include kids in enrolled in your
public school so if you had
homeschoolers or non-public school kids
and I say non-public schools we use the
term non-public school in New Hampshire
not private school just remember that
also when writing laws because that's
that can be tricky um but so non-public
school kids if those kids are in your
town you're not receiving adequacy for
those kids um so when a student leaves
um a public school to take an EFA once
the kid is no longer there then the
public school would not receive any
additional funds for that child um so
the phase out Grant was a a grant that
was implemented as part of this program
to subsidize for the fact that the
students are leaving to allow the school
districts to have time to account for
the kids leaving so in the very first
year that there's no kid they' receive
100% of their aid because that is
working in one year in a re like regular
adequacy and the second year that the
kid leaves you get a grant of 50% of the
adequacy that would be calculated for
that student and it's a very precise
calculation so if the student was an
English language learner and a special
education kid you get that amount for
that kid if they were just an English if
they were just a base kid then you get
just the base amount and we actually
even account for if the kid was in the
public school half of the year you would
get half of that amount those when you
asked before that 08 kid it's being
accounted for in this formula as well um
and then the last year um you get 25%
and so it kind of creates layers for
these kids um and so we on the
spreadsheet or the sheet here you have
the colors the colors are really helpful
because it kind of helps you follow the
years that those kids would be getting
the schools would be getting grants for
those kids um and the phase out Grant in
law it ends on July 1st
2026 um so that means that the kids that
take um an EFA for fiscal year 26 those
are the last kids that would receive a
phase out Grant and no additional phase
out grants would be paid after that to
public
schools and then um the information in
is actually it's just a a very long
document but it just kind of it shows
you the calculation and it shows you
which schools are Act which kids have
actually left um or which districts have
actually left and they're receiving a
phase out grant for those kids so that's
the information there and again you have
a town by town in the packet and that is
it oh and the last thing that I put on
your packet um is a document from the
children's Scholarship Foundation um but
these are the um poverty guidelines for
eligibility for Education Freedom
account so the first year that the
program passed it was 300% of federal
poverty um and then year three and four
are 350% of federal poverty so there's
some questions or there some Bill
proposals to change it to 5 100% or
other numbers and so these kind of I
just put this there for informational
purposes so you would have
this any other questions represent wer
is there uh any example of an EFA
student going from one District to
another public school there are yes not
very many but there are a few is there a
problem with that they're bringing the
EFA Grant but they're not bringing the
same amount of money that the students
have funded for right so just like a um
District public school could charge
tuition to another District Public
School the district public school could
charge a tuition amount to the EFA
student um and they can set that tuition
amount um there's nothing in this law
that requires them to set that tuition
amount on a certain amount um so the
student can use their EFA and then
potentially additional funds that they
have accessible to them as a family um
if the tuition amount is higher than the
amount of the EFA thank
you Rob on Kelly thank you I have
several questions go right through them
okay so um could you please walk us
through how those EFA accounts
work it's a you're referring to it as a
wallet is that like a debit card or how
does that work um that would be a
question that would be better for the
scholarship organization that implements
the program the department doesn't do
that work
directly okay so how would I ask that
question of them um just I think email
it I that would be the best thing would
be to email them directly
okay all right still have um I
understand that the money in the EFA
account is non-aps and it can roll over
from year to year so I'm wondering if
there's a limmit to how many years that
lapse can
continue um so as long as the student is
enrolled in the program the funds can
roll over um once the kid um finish
finishes their education the funding
would come back to the education trust
fund um but it it it can roll over for
the time that the student is in the
program so that's possible to be sort of
a 10year 12E rollover um in in theory if
you weren't using any of the funds um to
educate the child but you would think
you know if you're educating the kids
funding is coming from someplace
okay okay
um Can the student or the family use the
money
for a college account um and other words
in here in the RS in the
rsas under 19 4 F2 there's M says
tuition and fees at an institution of
higher education so is that how does
that work if the student reaches age 18
or
graduates what does this line mean for
higher education is that college so it's
supposed to be for kids kindergarten
through grades 12 um as far as what
isn't isn't educationally appropriate
for that student the scholarship
organization has the ability to
determine that so the scholarship
organization may be able to tell you
when when they are are not accessing
that
line so at the very end when the student
graduates 18 or graduates if there's any
money left in the account those funds
are supposed to come back to the state
yes so I suppose uh do you can you tell
me how that happens do so the
scholarship organization um we actually
do a Reconciliation process with the
scholarship organization every year
where we look at all of the kids that we
disperse funds for um and we can see for
example if the child left the education
Freedom account and went back to a
public school um and that would show up
on the public schools roster and this is
something that happens throughout the
years a pretty intensive reconciliation
process where we review the child um we
would reduce any remaining account or we
would um we would calculate the
remaining account and the scholarship
organization would review that and
reduce any remaining funds in the in the
account and give them back to us for
that appropriate time of period of time
okay
okay I think that's that's it for now
okay I have others but I'll wait go
ahead if you well I'm not sure if you
can answer this I'm wondering about the
Amazon account we were told before that
um the family can access an Amazon
account I'm wondering if there's a list
of books that are provided to the family
or the student yeah that again would be
a question for um scholarship
organization so I would remind you that
the legislature has determined that the
scholarship organization is the group
that is responsible for implementing
this program the department of
education's um Authority kind of ends
with uh it I believe it says the
Department of Education shall transfer
to a scholarship organization an amount
for the EFA um so the Department of
Education has um you know oversight
relative to to the contract but as far
as deter determining what is and isn't
educationally appropriate for the
student that the legislature wrote the
law so that that is the responsibility
of the scholarship organization okay
thank
you Al said you're still looking okay
representative papovich thank you Mr
chair um just to make sure that you know
everybody on the committee is on the
same page would it be accurate to say
that
the only appropriate use of any funds in
an EFA account is for the education of
that child that the uh you know account
is in the name of yes thank you and um
just to follow up on one of the
questions from my
colleague did you see any meaningful
amount of money being returned to you
through that process where the student
reaches the end of their K through 12
education and there is still unspent
money in the account any anything any
color you can add to I don't know off of
the top of my head um relative to
students ending the program um I do know
that there are far a fair number of
students that at the beginning of the
year consider an EFA account and then
throughout the course of the Year return
to public school and so that
reconciliation process we are um very
confident in that reconciliation process
but there are a fair number of kids that
do go back to their public school and so
then therefore the scholarship
organization returns all those
additional funds and the way that works
is is that the public school reports to
us the day that they returned to public
school and then we calculate the amount
of money that they would have received
through that period of time thank you
and Mr chair if I may suggest given that
there is interesting conversations with
the scholarship organization would it be
possible to uh you know maybe ask Mr
landrian to see if they would be willing
to come in and talk to us at a later
date so we can you know get everything
straight from the horse's mouth on tape
and all that
thank
you representative Murray thank you very
much uh so there's a little hole in my
brain can you connect sort of the dots
to whom is the scholarship organization
accountable if they're not accountable
to you to you the Department of
Education to whom are they accountable
um so the scholarship organization is
responsible for following all of the
laws in RSA 194f and there's a bunch of
different things that the scholarship
organization has to do within certain
things with in certain time periods so
there's certain reporting that they have
to do for the Department of Education
there's certain report reporting that
they have to do to the Department of
Revenue because they're registered under
77g there's certain requirements that
they're required to do because they're a
nonprofit to the charal trust unit at
the Attorney General's office um and
there's um also reporting there's a
legislative oversight committee for the
education Freedom accounts that um the
scholarship organization attends so
there are a fair number of um different
things throughout um RSA 194f and all um
the New Hampshire
laws thank you again so some of us have
been looking for some of these documents
to see you know what accountability
proposals or you know follow-ups that
they're doing and we're having a hard
time finding this information um if we
wanted to be able to examine the
documents that support the
accountability how would we do that um I
would recommend talking to the children
Scholarship Foundation um the documents
that they're required to report to the
Department of Education the Department
of Education makes available or the
summary of the documents a lot of the
information they provide to the
Department of Education is student
identifiable information so it's
summarized say like in the town by Town
kind of calculations here or our various
um different different reconciliation
processes um but the children's
Scholarship Foundation would be the best
uh group for that thank
you the legislative oversight committee
also did uh file an report in November
so I can circulate that to the committee
so you've got that as well thank
you any other
questions any other comments that's all
we had prepared for you today um you
guys went through Mark stuff very Qui
quick just to be fair um but so um on
Wednesday we'll be back um we are going
to do um Kelly Rambo is our
administrator of our food and nutrition
program and that's not any material
materials that you've received in the
past from us we didn't do anything on
that on orientation day so she's going
to talk you through um the federal and
any state re responsibilities around
food and nutrition programs um and then
some of the various different
legislative proposals Mark will be here
too um to discuss the impacts of the
free and reduced lunch program on some
of these other Aid programs because
that's one of the things you know we're
seeing free and reduced lunch
eligibility as the proxy for poverty
here in education but so if you're
changing um eligibility requirements on
that side of things it could impact some
of these other programs so we'll be here
to talk about that um we will also have
um Tim Carney to talk about uh the
building facilities program he'll talk
about building Aid lease Aid and safe
grants Public School infrastructure
grants um Mickey did we have oh we were
talking about Jeff right oh special
education special educ Melissa will be
here to talk about special education um
and we know there's a lot of proposed
legislation and questions and concern
concerns relative to um the state
special education formula specifically
so she'll be here to talk about that and
then we have we can have Jeff but I
don't know if we'll have time for him
yeah maybe Jeff on another day but that
so the topics so and and back to the um
the packet the one that says um ETF
District before you get that who's the
last person you mumbled about there oh
Jeff is the administrator of the career
and Tech education program so does he
speak a
lot uh so we were just thinking with the
number of programs ahead of that it
might be a lot for that afternoon so if
we don't get to tuition and
transportation or CT programs we'll make
sure the department can answer those
questions when they come in with their
budget hearing after the budget comes
out and and Melissa will be here so I
don't think we were going to have Jeff
but Melissa who is the director of um
those Bureau will be here and we'll be
able to talk about it high level too
this might be helpful to get some over
side of that before we actually get into
the budget when we're going to be more
focused on the numbers so that's fine if
if she can present it that that's that's
totally fine you don't need to bring
bring a special person in um I'll talk
to her and Jeff and see what's available
um but so I was just going to remind you
so on the original packet here the
education funding orientation ones is
ETF so this one is kind of these are all
the things that you're going to probably
need to make decisions on relative to
the Department's budget um the
department other you know the other
things in our budget are I'd say im
material compared to these programs and
these are the ones that the impacts go
directly to school districts you can see
measurable impacts on your towns that
you represent when you're looking at
these programs so these are the things
that you're going to want to make
decisions on that are going to be
probably the harder decisions that you
have to make throughout this budget
process um and so we've covered the
majority of them but if there's
something on here that you're seeing
that we don't cover today and Wednesday
definitely let me know um and we can do
that as
well so so is that the orientation one
you were talking about yeah yep um the
one that says ETF and School District
Finance documents
it's the the larger one that Mark
had wrong
one she named them differently in the I
took the date off yeah when I sent them
digitally I took the date off yes yeah a
subtitle
okay trying to recycle your file names
and your document names are different
try trying to recycle these as much as
possible you know we're trying to have
one thing so we can talk about it
consistently throughout the so it helps
us help you so essentially we referring
to that page two one yes page two it
just lists the big education trust fund
items okay thank
you good anything else across the board
here no okay thank you very much thank
you
U division two meeting is adjourned
thank you very much
thank you Mr Lando again